so he's got uh is it the daily wire is
that what it's called daily wire so this
is like a subscription Media company
that he created because they're just
sort of like anti-mainstream media that
became a big thing like fake news and F
the mainstream media well why don't we
create an alternative the daily wire and
the daily wire does some insane numbers
it's like only in year three or four or
something like this very new and it does
over 100 million a year in subscription
Revenue yeah and have you heard of their
their spin-off Jeremy's razors
dude you've got to go to this
[Music]
foreign dude I've had a hell of a of a
of a day I'm not gonna say who but check
this out
a friend wanted to come skateboarding
with me so naturally he got a concussion
so I took him to the hospital by the way
did you even get like an hour of
skateboarding in or was this like five I
got an hour in I got an hour in uh yeah
and then he was getting hyped up seeing
me do stuff he fell hit his head take
him to the hospital to get his
concussion checked out turns out while
we while we were there while they were
getting the scan their appendix ruptured
and they get rushed overnight or they
get they have to stay there overnight
get rushed to the a different hospital
emergency appendix surgery so this head
injury basically saved his life and they
were like I don't know like this is just
a gift from God but you definitely could
have died from this did the appendix get
damaged in the skateboard fall or no
just separately happen to be the same
time separate it's just a weird turn of
events very separate so that's where
I've been so I'm a little disheveled but
I'm wearing my cool guy jacket now
that's my new thing I'm gonna be the
token cool guy you could be the nerd
congrats no this is real leather bro
this thing this ain't Tesla vegan
leather but I'm in my cool guy outfit so
I'm good to go
yeah
um cool is what I would describe that as
so that's
uh all right where where shall we start
where do you want to start are we still
is Sam still showing up to the BYOB
empty-handed or is he bringing ideas to
the table where are we at with this
whole uh well Sam does research thing I
know you started with a doctor's note
there so is that your excuse for why you
don't have any topics we I just went
over a lot of my topics I was the one
who did the topics um oh you want to
talk about your new seed oil only diet
isn't that what you told me that you're
doing a seed oil only diet
so like seed oils are all the rage right
now is it just in my world we start
talking about them and now I'm seeing
everywhere people are so anti-seed oils
my friend Dennis was like screw it I'm
only eating seed oils from now on I
looked yesterday at the bag of um I was
like you know what I kind of want to
have one of these little little bag of
this little pretzel thing for a second I
just let me just check the check the
stats on this I was like ah it's not so
bad not too many calories whatever and I
looked at the the ingredients
I saw canola oil on there or something
like that you know sunflower oil
whatever these things are and it was a
Sam voice in my head that just told me
these things kill you and so I decided I
decided to put it down I drank a big
tall glass of water instead so pretty
pretty big net win there for me yeah I
don't know why it's bad for you but
someone on Twitter told me it was
therefore it's true if it's if it's
written down on Twitter or if it Rhymes
or if it's like a cute phrase I
automatically believe it alliterations
Rhymes or four people I don't know
either any one of those three and I'm in
let me tell you uh two things one you
said something about like oh it's
beautiful it's well done and it reminded
me I uh yesterday I found anime what
would be an amazing DDC product not
amazing like hundreds of millions of
dollars but uh
a DDC business that is I know would just
it would work it would work really well
it would be very profitable
um I'm looking uh if somebody wants to
operate it I I'll I will just simply
give you an idea in a Playbook and then
uh I'll take my share and we can we can
start this company but basically it
would require somebody who's good at
things that are beautifully done so this
I think requires the feminine touch so
I'm sort of fishing in a dry Pond here
with this with this podcast but uh to
our four female listeners if any any of
the four of you you've got a 25 chance
each here to uh to step in and take it
or um to one of our male uh listeners if
you I don't know see a female today let
her know about this opportunity I'm
looking for somebody who could do
something that is uh the product is
beautifully done it would be a
successful d2c product I have no doubt
in my mind uh you just need to be good
at a couple things you know
an aesthetically beautiful brand and
short form video content tick tocks or
getting them made by other people if you
don't do them yourself but easier all
right you have been the palm of your
hand tell me what it is
um I can't tell you on air because I
don't want everybody to copy it I will
tell you off air wait really yes
dude this was the lamest segment ever
is that really it that's really what you
want to do that's really what I'm going
to do here if it happens then we can we
can reveal it uh and if it doesn't
happen then I'll also reveal because I
have nothing to lose at that point so
just not yet I I was gonna remind people
this is usually a segment where I remind
people of our Gentleman's Agreement
where we work for you now but all you
have to do is go to our YouTube channel
And subscribe that's a gentleman's
agreement it's called The Gentleman's
Agreement because I can't check to see
if it's true so it's just based on trust
but
all right I'm in The Penalty Box but I'm
gonna fight my way out okay so here we
go I tweeted something out the other day
that I think is very interesting and
reminds me of the Doug demuro a YouTube
Creator yeah a YouTube Creator who's not
just gonna make money off YouTube ad
Revenue but has built a business that
they built basically a 50 million dollar
plus Empire off YouTube why did I ask
this question well your boy's gonna
start doing YouTube content but your boy
also wants to make more than 50 million
dollars doing this process and so I
wanted to see who has done this before
because I'm not really interested in
being a Pioneer the Pioneers get
slaughtered right so I don't want to be
a Pioneer doing this I want to be sort
of a fast follower so I was looking for
examples and I got a bunch out of this
tweet I want to read some of them off to
you and see what you think about these
first one by the way when you tweeted
that
I don't know if it's because I know you
well or if everyone like could read
through the lines here but it was very
much like uh tell me what to do with my
life yeah yeah yeah yeah like hey can
you just um can you validate my parking
pass here yeah I need some need
something so first one's right up your
alley more plates more dates more place
more dates you probably know this story
a little better than I do I didn't know
he was doing this because I watched his
videos he doesn't really pump product as
much uh or at least in the clips that
I've seen if you watch closely he does
not not in an obnoxious way right so
this guy Derek super likable guy uh puts
out great content I'm not even really
interested in like
testosterone and like steroid usage and
something else occasionally I am with
certain athletes but usually not but I
find myself just watching this guy's
videos because I like this guy a lot
um apparently he's got a brand or maybe
two Brands one brand uh you know the
name of it yeah one's called Merrick
health and the other one is called
gorilla what's real mind gorilla mind
yeah so gorilla mind if you go to
gorilla mine gorilla mind is getting I
want to say almost two million uh
between one and two million uh visits a
month right so let's say a million
visits a month
I think it's pretty safe that this that
this brand is doing about a million
dollars a month in Revenue so 12 million
a year in revenue on his uh supplements
brand I think more I I would take the I
would take the the more on that one yeah
uh yeah that's a I would say a
conservative estimate uh would I
wouldn't be surprised if it was as high
as four million a month
um and supplements are an amazing Niche
to be in right like everybody wants to
be in the uh everybody wants to be in
the supplements Niche so
um so that's great just gave me by the
way two pronunciations of Niche uh back
to back just to appeal to both both
sides of the aisle you totally redeemed
yourself
and then Merrick is this trt clinic so
they basically do kind of like you know
uh help men you know stay young so
hormone replacement hair loss sexual
Wellness all this stuff
um this thing's got to be doing pretty
well too and I think they also do the
semi-glue tied stuff uh as well I don't
did he start this or what because it has
like 200 employees on LinkedIn is just a
partner or he started it I think he's an
equity owner I don't know if he's the
guy but I think it's he's he's so
popular that it appears as though he's a
a main guy and he's definitely pulling
his weight I know a lot of people he
used Merrick health I don't know anyone
who uses gorilla mine I think gorilla
mine's a horrible name for a supplement
company uh but I trust Derek I think The
Branding on this is wrong but it's
interesting and it's what's really
interesting is like he sells creatine do
anything about creatine it's awesome for
one and number two it's basically like
have you ever heard of creatine it's
awesome
I'm almost positive that creatine is
like a commodity like it's almost like
all the same uh and and he's selling it
but he has an upset here he has a he
marked it up because it's Derek um but
yeah that's a good example of a Creator
killing it and by the way these examples
I specifically said I said you get
kicked out of the party if you come here
and you say Joe Rogan or Mr B started
like it has to be somebody else like not
the examples everybody always talks
about so here's here's a couple others
okay so here's some that uh I'll go in
order of the ones you know to the ones I
think you don't know so another one you
know Kayla
I don't know how you say her last name
Kayla izinis I think so no I think it's
like it's new or something I think it's
pronounced a little bit different but
but if you're if you're one of the four
women listeners they 100 know who she is
trying to pronounce like uh Hermes or
something like that on this podcast or
like Hermes yeah you know I got a lot of
[__] for that
um yeah one time I heard you pronounce
it you're not exactly good at
pronouncing pronouncing things my mouth
doesn't fully work yeah I got a thick
tongue
uh so she created this app so she's like
a fitness influencer type person ends up
creating an app called The Sweat app I
believe they sold it for 400 million
dollars so her and her
husband or boyfriend and then they broke
up but they kept building the business
together I don't know what ended up
happening there but it sounded like
there was some drama uh 400 million
dollars on this exit so I thought that
was a great example of not just saying
cool I'm gonna hold up a detox tea and
you know get paid five thousand dollars
for a shout out I'm actually going to
create a business off of my following
um Mark Rober so Mark Rober yeah he's a
former NASA engineer he makes like
engineering videos like oh I built the
world's biggest T-shirt cannon I love
this guy he built it yeah he's a really
likable guy he's like you know the
science teacher everyone's favorite
science teacher type of guy he has a
monthly subscription box I think that
does like it's like a science kit and
you're like you get to build little
products yourself and that's a great
idea super on brand uh it's 25 30 bucks
um
this thing is I I think doing millions
of dollars
um a year pretty safely he's got a very
very big following 23 million I think on
YouTube I mean he's like one of the big
guys yeah he's been around for a long
time
um okay another one you probably know
Ben Shapiro so Ben Shapiro is um by the
way I'm gonna make a little prediction
you don't agree with everything he says
but you kind of love this guy
yeah
I'm objecting I also feel the same way
yeah I like his nerd Swagger and he's
he's just fast-mouthed he just like says
things very succinctly and quickly and I
don't believe in most of the things he
says I believe maybe some of them he's
pretty religious uh and I'm not into I'm
not into religion but he says a lot of
stuff that I'm like
dude just the fact that you came with
that like pretty brutal reply so quickly
I respect you yeah it's like a rap
battle right like you just at the end of
the day you know whoever kind of insults
the other person the fastest and the
best wins and uh he does not have a
thick tongue like your boys uh do so
he's at that thin time yeah he's good
man so he's got uh is it the daily wire
is that what it's called daily wire so
this is like a subscription media
company that he created because they're
just sort of like anti-mainstream media
that became a big thing like fake news
and F the mainstream media well why
don't we create an alternative the daily
wire and the daily wire does some insane
numbers it's like only in year three or
four or something like this very new
and it does over 100 million a year in
subscription Revenue
yeah and have you heard of their their
spin-off Jeremy's razors
no dude you've got to go to this so go
to it's just Google like daily wire
Razer company but so basically uh dollar
share or Harry's razor was one of their
spots so basically Ben Shapiro's
conservative or he's right-wing whatever
he's you call him and so naturally like
the left hates him
um and the right uh loves him because
they feel like they're being canceled
all the time and so Harry's Razors was
one of their biggest or big advertisers
and they bailed they you know said you
know we're not going to associate with
Ben you know you're screwed up and so
the founder or one of the co-founders
and CEO of the daily wire his name is
Jeremy and so if you go to Jeremy's
razors you'll see the website and they
made this crazy video where they just
said like it's actually pretty hilarious
regardless if you agree with them or not
but they created this video that's like
a hype video and it was launched nine
months ago and it has 22 million views
and they're selling millions and
millions of dollars they basically just
took the Harry's razors like it's pretty
much their site is identical to Harry's
Razors but they just go taught Jeremy's
razors and it's like and the picture is
this guy who's he's like smoking a cigar
it's basically a big middle finger to uh
to Harry's Razors on the about page it
says Harry's in the daily wire had a
deal they paid us we advertised their
razors but after we said that boys our
boys and girls are girls they probably
condemned our views as inexcusable uh
and misaligned and you know what uh
you're damn right our values are
misaligned we value truth and the right
to speak we Embrace masculinity and the
courage to uphold it and so that's like
the whole shtick it's Us Versus Them
regardless of what you feel about that
if you think it's right or wrong very uh
they capitalized on something and it's
and it's doing well this is so good this
is uh wow this is an amazing amazing
little case here the video that's the
like ad the launch video for this it
starts with a it's like it's like
professionally made and basically starts
with like you hear like a car and you're
in a parking lot and it shows like the
parking signs and it's like um you know
the daily wire and then it says god king
and a guy pulls up in a McLaren and he
gets out with a like a blowtorch and he
goes inside and just blow torches a
bunch of like Harry's um like
merchandise and just sets it on fire and
it's like uh such a such a smart thing
to do to take this like great business
model right the the classic kind of
Gillette you know um Razer cartridge
model and then just be like no this is
the one done by by us for us right like
um yeah that is so smart and
I feel like that just opens the door for
them to do this in five other categories
yeah it's a very very intriguing uh case
study of what these guys are doing so
yeah that's a good one can you write the
word Jeremy on a stick of deodorant yes
you can all right Greg can you write
Jeremy on a tub of toothpaste great yep
you sure can uh what else can I write
the word Jeremy on that's not there's
now a guy running around grocery stores
being like we can write Jeremy on that
we can write Jeremy on this oh my God
guys the opportunity is massive yeah
they're like hey Republicans like
sunscreen let's do that white people get
sunburned this is yeah totally work yeah
interesting case study all right what
else is there all right so then there's
kind of like the Emma Chamberlain a lot
of people talk about her coffee thing
people know that
um
uh Pat McAfee
killing it you know he kind of did he
did a hundred a four-year 120 million
dollar deal with FanDuel for his NFL
show which is
pretty insane
um that's like a absolutely insane like
brand deal to pull off okay then there's
some others that I hadn't even heard of
so he's also the host of like WWE do you
know that he's like an announcer there
he's kind of Crossing I went down a very
deep McFly Rabbit Hole one night because
I was like I think I love this guy he's
amazing
and I was like I'm doing this for the
Pod This research and then
three hours in I was like this isn't for
the Pod this is for my soul I I just
enjoyed this is watching this whole
journey and I was also like I don't
think there's even a story here for the
podcast I just think I really like this
content and I'm and I never talked about
it I just did three hours one night and
I just never brought it up there was one
time where I thought about our setup and
I'm like we should do it standing up
because he stands up when he records and
I love it he also wears a tank top which
I know you love yeah so win-win
um all right so here's some others that
I didn't even know who these people are
Danny Austin you ever heard that have
you ever heard of this person no okay so
she created a brand called Divi and it's
basically scalp care for women so she
basically took a problem in her life
which was I think maybe like as she was
aging or postpartum maybe she was
struggling with hair loss which is
actually pretty common for women to
struggle with hair loss
um like I know my wife like after we had
every time like you you go kind of like
after you have a baby uh like your
body's just producing whatever different
hormones and there's like they all like
complain about like you know their hair
thinning or hair loss it's a very common
thing so anyways um she creates a brand
she first was just talking about the
struggle and then she stole the solution
so her content was everyone's like oh my
God Danny so vulnerable so authentic oh
my God so like I'm so glad you're
speaking up on these issues and like
you're a beautiful queen you're so
beautiful this is like don't worry about
it and then she sold a solution which
was like the scalp care thing and she
did 20 million dollars in the first like
10 months or something that's crazy so
it just like took off right away like a
rocket
um so I like that one there's another
way do you ever watch dandruff videos on
Tick Tock that's like my favorite type
of content people just like flaking off
dandruff you ever do that people like
people like popping zits too dude
because I got crazy dandruff if I like
itch my head there's gonna be a snow day
I'm always looking for like a good a
good dandruff shampoo and I love
watching dandruff videos on Tick Tock
it's a huge Niche don't wear black
around Sam yeah
not good
um so there's this woman named Mindy
McKnight this is another cool example so
she started a brand called cute girl
hair where she was because she was just
doing hairstyles YouTube yeah great name
honestly amazing name uh yeah she was
making YouTube content just doing
hairstyles for her girls that's cool
content oh here's how we do this
hairstyle here's how we do this one
um it's kind of like you know what your
big sister should have taught you or
something like that and uh I think her
story is like she has five kids I might
butcher the story because I just I don't
remember this was like a couple weeks
ago when I saw this but like I think
she's got five kids or something like
that and they all have different
hairstyles or textures they may have
adopted or something like that and so
she's like her content is showing like
this wide range of like hairstyles and
how you can make them all look cute no
matter what your hair is right that's
great
she does a launch with Walmart and it's
the second biggest launch with Walmart
she just they're doing nine figures in
sale so over a hundred million in sales
um and her YouTube channel has five and
a half million uh Subs
um her twin daughters have YouTube have
a YouTube channel with seven million
Subs right like this is just kind of
insane how big that launch can be when
it's like total alignment between
Creator their personal story their
content and then the product once they
have the distribution and so that was
pretty inspiring to me I really like
that and now uh now I have a good excuse
to spend all day
just making fun content for free and
being like don't worry
one day
this is all gonna become actual like
this will this will be real work this is
not just me getting to play around and
like you know be on YouTube all day all
right well what else is there I mean
cute girl hero great name what else you
got
uh well okay I just gave you seven but
like we can keep going if we if we like
Oh I thought you had a few I there's one
one guy that I find very fascinating
that I saw someone mention on your thing
Gooseman
I didn't know who this was a lot of
people mentioned him so Guzman he's I
guess a fitness influencer he's got
athlete or something like that alphaly
yeah his I don't know if his knit I
think his Niche is like Texans I think
he's hispanic so I think he has like a
huge Hispanic following but basically
basically he's like a rip a rip guy but
he like has like weaved in his family
into his content so you like know about
his life and he's like a family guy he
launched something like a 50 000 square
foot gym called Alpha land uh so
probably not in your wheelhouse but it's
called Alpha land and uh sister Branch
for uh dudes yeah you go there to watch
what's going on is that like a
gymnastics like part of the stream
we stretch and watch other men workout
yeah it's called Alpha land it's like a
50 000 square foot gym I forget where it
is San Antonio or Houston or Dallas or
one of those folks one of those places
where you'd expect an alpha land and uh
and he also has a clothing line and I
think he's killing it I think he's doing
a he's big business right I like say you
acted like you hadn't been there or
don't have a membership but like
um uh okay yeah so this is my these are
my 50 million dollar creators and all
these people I think have built off of
their YouTube content uh United Empire
that's easily worth 50 million or more
uh you um you you made fun of me for not
preparing and you prepared that list I
think I knew more about all of them than
you did yeah because you were you're
like a real consumer of content
um right like I'll be like oh they use
this technology in this music video
you're like yeah I love that music video
and I'm like I haven't watched a music
video and it literally it's been 17
years since I've watched a single music
video I went to your house and you just
had music videos on TV on Loop I love
music videos I was like this is what you
watch and you're like I just leave it on
[Laughter]
I ran out of questions because I was
like wow this is just a different thing
that just doesn't happen in my world no
I watch music videos constantly so yeah
that's one of the ways I know about
stuff also my wife is a little bit
younger so she just turned 30 so when we
were dating you know only a couple years
ago she was like in my 20s okay yeah
well hey I said younger than me and
she's got a younger sister so I'm kinda
I'm I got my toe in the cool kids Market
yeah you like you see people you leave
the house you take supplements you watch
music videos you watch movies you read
biographies you do a lot of things that
like you know I simply don't do I'm like
a I'm just like a heat-seeking missile
for like what's the interesting story
and then my stories are typically like
uh did you know that there's this and
then for most normal people are like
yeah I love that I love their Channel
you're watching them October for years
you're a potato what you see is what you
get you can pull the skin back a little
bit it gets something new I'm like
you're an onion bro there's layers
there's lots of layers it goes all the
way to the core the layers don't stop
yeah but french fries are made out of me
and I think that that's kind of a win
dude all right let me tell you something
interesting and this is more so I want
to put this on record that I brought
this up about two years ago but have I
remember when I told you about the
company bring a trailer
yeah yeah you said um you said you were
talking about
um car companies or auction companies or
something like that and you were like
dude there's this thing you've been told
that this is like a long time ago before
a long time ago you were like dude
there's this thing called bring a
trailer it's sick you can just buy a car
on this auction thing I don't even know
how it works exactly you're like it
started by this guy Doug no you're
confusing two things it was the guy from
uh inbox or whatever right yeah yeah so
it was started the main guy I forget his
name Nathan I think the the non-main guy
but also co-founder I think his name is
Gentry Underwood and he started uh this
company called mailbox which is like an
email thing that sold for uh reportedly
100 million dollars to Dropbox like
before it even launched because it built
up such a huge waitlist and it sounded
like a cool product I don't even think
it got launched but anyway it's this
website called bring a trailer and if
you go to it it just looks like almost
like a Blog it's a it's fairly
unsophisticated honestly I think it's
WordPress
and what they do is there's this neat
niche of car enthusiasts who like things
from like the 70s to like early 90s
which
I don't like my jacket yeah yeah exactly
like my jacket and it started out small
but it sold recently and it was recently
ish announced that they last year in the
trailing 12 months sold something like
1.2 billion dollars worth of cars in one
year and they made something like 100
million dollars in net revenue with like
80 employees and you go to their website
and it's so basic and people love it and
there's this guy named Doug demuro who
has a YouTube channel where he reviews
all types of cars and he does it just
within like an iPhone and he like always
has like have you know like a bacon
collar have you heard of a bacon collar
it's like where you wear an undershirt
on your on your shirt in your white
shirt the collar is all like shuffled or
like the the the white sleeves are like
coming down below your Polo you know
what I'm talking about okay so your
undershirt is showing is that the idea
yeah where you're like under like he's
like it's like where you're wearing like
imagine a guy wearing cargo shorts and
like an Old Navy T-shirt with like a
Hollister Polo above it and like you
have a bacon collar like he just looks
totally disheveled it's incredibly
unprofessional looking okay I got the
definition
shirts that have a wavy neck due to
being stretched out or from improper
care yeah it's just like it's just like
the very typical like oh my shirts look
yeah you're a bacon color guy so that's
what this guy is Doug's a a bacon collar
guy but he's hilarious and he's lovable
and he's likable and he's built this
YouTube channel like he'll review like a
two million dollar Ferrari as well as
like a thirty thousand dollar Honda
Pilot and it's right pretty hilarious
he's got three or four million
subscribers on YouTube now I told you
about two years ago maybe I forget what
maybe three years ago he launched this
new company called cars and bids and
it's very similar to bring a trailer and
so I predict that this is actually going
to be a multi 100 million dollar exit
and I want to make my prediction there
now that that's going to happen but
what's really interesting here is
curated auctions I think that's very
fascinating because the reason it's
fascinating is if you go to eBay have
you been to eBay in the last like five
years I have not dude no like not a lot
of people do of course A lot of people
do but like not a lot of people do and
it's because it's one of those things no
one goes there anymore perfect
description it's got like 100 million
visitors you don't know any of them yeah
it's too crowded no one goes here
anymore
um and so it's one of those things where
like you go to eBay and you like that
one
it was really the timing that I enjoyed
it
you go to eBay and you get overwhelmed
with options and there's a couple of
businesses that I've been looking at
where I'm trying to think of what a
curated auction could be because I think
it's like I think it's cool and it feels
it's just a beautiful experience you
know that's what we that's our phrase
it's just like one option but it's just
beautifully done yeah it's beautifully
done really well done anytime people can
say like hand crafted or like Ultra
Premium uh that's what this is and I
really have been digging this I invested
in a company that is doing this for
homes because I've been looking at like
what are big ticket items that people
will buy online that they previously
didn't but they will because it's more
well curated so like for example we
talked about uh I can never say it right
but hodinki we had Kevin Rose the
founder they sell like you can buy like
a forty thousand dollar watch online and
they do a really good job of
editorializing it so I've been thinking
what are other categories where someone
can buy something online that's 30 to
100 000 even a million dollars plus but
if you curate it nicely and you describe
it nicely with beautiful photos so in
the same way that Airbnb I don't know if
you know this but they used to send out
photographers to the really nice
listings because they're like we charge
a thousand dollars a night with better
pictures you can charge fifteen hundred
dollars a night so it's worth worth it
to us to help you make your [__] look
better what else is like that that these
curated auctions can can work out
because I think they're really really
cool companies to to run and they're
really hard to break once they work once
they work it's like the people working
there you guys are important but like
the community has taken you are you are
just a um uh
you you're just there to to help the
community it's no longer your business
that you're pushing down people's
throats golf equipment
golf equipment golf equipment really
how much is an expensive how much why do
you say that well you have an Enthusiast
Market you have a kind of like a
knowledge gap of uh which one should I
get what's better what's worse blah blah
blah you have a super premium price
point and I think a golfer over the
course of their lifetime is going to
spend you know probably upwards of ten
thousand dollars on equipment and I
think that so because I think because I
think the the thing you want is like
cars you want a high ticket right you
need you need a high ticket you need
ability to drive high ticket customers
to something and so I think that's one
where people will nerd out on the
content and um and get there but I have
other this what you said by the way is a
perfect lead into two things I want to
talk about wait let me say mine
livestock livestock like animals hell
yeah dog dude my my so listen to this my
cousins they're they're cowboys so they
Buck Bowl
it's called if you ask them what they do
they'll go I Buck balls which means they
live in rural Oklahoma and and when I
went to their house once and instead of
like it was a Thursday night and instead
of going like the community softball
game we went to the community rodeo and
there was only like 20 people in the
stands but they are practicing their
Rodeo which is basically you get on a
bowl and bowls are mean bulls want to
kill you even if they even if you raised
them they're just like mean and they get
on these bowls and they Buck them off
and the bull the person who stays on the
longest gets a prize but the bull who
bucks the hardest based off of like
judging wins a prize and some of these
balls cost 50 Grand my parents bought
into a bowl for fifty thousand dollars
and they get a portion of the like The
Offspring like the the the sperm that
they they sell and they get a portion of
the winnings from the bowl
they make money off of it yeah and they
it's like what kind of money are we
talking here what did it do
the return's not like that great but
like you like I don't know you get a
couple grand every once in a while so
it's like not that great and like the
bowl can like break its leg and you're
screwed but but should we go have these
on a bull it is pretty interesting to
own a bowl but it's a it's a huge sport
in certain parts of the country my
cousin went to college on a scholarship
for bucking bulls for being a rodeo guy
and so and all these folks they they
it's cash so they'll come to the rodeo
with like 10 30 40 grand in cash and
they're like playing right there on it
it's very fascinating you've never been
to a Livestock Auction
sure haven't uh dude it's dope but it's
awesome I do think we should go have
these on a bowl uh if there's a bull
dealer in the audience uh hit us up we
are uh we're in the market for one uh
and we'll live stream our our bull
purchase
um yeah this is great okay uh okay so
livestock that's one yeah sure I like
that
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most trms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and it actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better
all right I think I've kind of done this
but I went even deeper down this Rabbit
Hole so I got to bring him back as a new
Billy of the week
[Applause]
[Music]
a million dollars isn't cool you know
it's cool a billion dollars
[Music]
the new Billy of the week is an old
Billy of the week it's Sam Altman and
you would think Sam what uh somebody you
know you got nothing new to say here
well Sam Altman we all know Sam Altman
we've talked about Sam Altman
dude Sam Altman's Sam Alvin's onion
status he's got layers uh okay so I want
to read you some of the interesting I
went down to Sam outman Rabbit Hole last
night here's why
he did an interview and I was I was
watching you got to explain who he is
for the news okay for people who don't
know Sam Altman is he's uh like an
entrepreneur in Silicon Valley he
created one company he didn't go that
far called looped uh sold it for 40
billion bucks then he but he admit he
went through y combinator the big
accelerator down here when he was like
19. and the founder of why common are
super impressed with him and kept him on
his partner and eventually named him
president of YC which is like one of
like it's like being named the dean of
Harvard after being a Harvard student
because the dean thought you were so
special and so that's literally what he
did he became the president of YC grew
YC he then created he then created the
non-profit open AI he then left to go
work on open AI open AI is now behind
chat GPT which is like one of the
fastest growing like Tech waves that's
out there basically in artificial
intelligence platform
that's I think they launched Chad GPT
and I think got 10 million users in like
10 days or something ridiculous like
that it's worth 40 billion dollars
companies worth you know somewhere
between 20 40 billion dollars now and uh
he's the you know the leader of that
thing too plus he's a prolific investor
was Investments all right so I got some
of those facts coming but that's and
most people know Sam Altman I'm not
bringing up a surprise if you listen to
you probably know who he is okay but
here's some of the things I didn't know
um
I was listening to this interview and
they go um you invested in this Fusion
company and I'm thinking okay if you're
gonna still don't know what the hell
that is but I know smart people talk
about it okay great and they go uh you
led the investment okay that's fine he
led the investment so you put you wrote
a 375 million dollar check into helian
uh and I was like what you know like
rewind what what did this person just
say and I literally went back and I
re-listened to it and I was and I was
like oh I didn't know Sam Altman has
like a giant Venture fund like uh
surely he's not writing a 375 million
dollar check himself
as far as I could tell that is what he
did he wrote a 360. check himself and
that got me down this Rabbit Hole up
where did how did Sam Altman get so
wealthy uh because I've heard several
stories now so for example
when he started open AI or even when he
was president of YC he donated 10
million dollars to um a science research
uh like
um a project that he created right like
science research nonprofit
to donate 10 million dollars means you
got a lot more than 10 million dollars
and at that time I was like how did he
get 10 million dollars because again his
first startup which he was like whatever
18 or 19. sold for 41 million dollars
out of that he said that he got five
million dollars so somehow he parlayed
five million dollars and in a very short
amount of time about four or five years
was now donating 10 million dollars that
was the first thing wow it was that
short that didn't make sense and I was
like okay so he's you know this is now
you know maybe six years Max later okay
then what else did he do he also
um
donated to you know when he started open
AI but they didn't say how much and then
this 375 million dollar check so I
started going back and trying to figure
out what's going on so
starts looped sells it and that's about
five million dollars from there how old
was he uh at that five million dollars
like 22 23 yeah something like that I
don't have the exact timeline but I
think he's in his young early 20s is
pretty safe to say there
um
he then uh starts investing in startups
and so he's investing in startups second
investment is
drumroll please the best investment of
the decade stripe so he's one of the
First Investors in stripe
um that was his second investment and
there's this like thing that I've
noticed which is uh in d2c Brands they
call your first kind of like couple
months
um your golden cohort it's like I
noticed this about our customers and my
Ecom brand but I noticed this across
many Brands uh which is your first that
first batch of customers you get for
some reason their LTV is way higher and
it kind of makes sense because it's
actually like the people who immediately
get it with your message are willing to
adopt your thing before you're a big
brand they probably really have the
problem or they're heavy enthusiasts
um there's some there's an equivalent
thing in investing for some reason it's
very common for People's First sort of
five to ten Investments to do extremely
well uh in the world of Angel Investing
when you're for for great investors
often their best hits come early like uh
Chris Saka who's one of the best early
stage investors of all time
his or one of some of his earliest
Investments were basically you know the
combination of Twitter Uber Instagram
you know things like that and they came
in kind of the first 10 15 deals that he
did and I feel like that's the only
stuff he did like those were the hits
and then everything he did so well he
retired right he became a billionaire
and essentially retired from the game
because he was like well my first fund
was like whatever 6000 x
I'm good
um
Sam said that in his first 40 deals
um at that at that time he had invested
in 40 deals
um he was two years in and he said that
uh five of the companies were doing
really good and then it was like what's
really good mean it was over 100 x
so what's up that's not really good
that's ridiculously good so what's a
what's a fifty thousand dollar how big
of it maybe 25 000 what's 100 times uh
25 000 well you're violating the no
public math rule but is that 2.5 or 25
million so 50 000 turns into 5 million
for 100x wow okay and so you stack five
of those that's pretty good right off
that that was like okay where do you get
all this money how was he doing all
these deals was he just investing out of
that 5 million and the reality was yes
he was investing personally but
um I texted a friend so I was like yo
I'm looking up Sam open like did he
write this check personally how did he
get all this money and this is somebody
else who's young smart and friends with
Sam and that crew and he's like I think
it was I think this check was personal
this 375 million dollar check because I
think so but it might have been an SPV
and I was like um I was like dude I feel
like there's like some underground uh
you know like team Prodigy thing where
like there is if you're if you turn 18
years old and you're like a Phenom Peter
Thiel just gives you 100 million dollars
and I was like I was laughing and I was
like you know I think you're in that
club too and he was just laughing he's
like oh yeah Peter does actually back it
so I go and I Google it sure enough Sam
Alvin right after he saw his first thing
races a 21 million dollar fund from
Peter Thiel they're 100 is dude I know a
few of these prodigies there is there is
a club they exist so people talk about
like uh like you know oh just like what
do they say uh you know it's that boys
club and I can't ever break into it
unfortunately that's true it's real they
exist you and I aren't in that club
maybe we have our own club but these
type of like Elite clubs they're real
they're 100 real so somebody said
something they were like you know Sam
they're asking Paul Graham I think
they're like What's what stood out to
you about Sam because from the very
beginning I've talked about this before
from the very beginning I think 2007
2008 Paul Graham wrote a blog post about
who are the five most impressive people
he's met in Silicon Valley or who does
he admirer look up to or whatever and it
was like Steve Jobs Larry and Sergey
from Google and Sam Altman and it was
like what one of these does not belong
one guy invented Apple another guy
invented Google who's this kid I've
never heard of and he was like
um when I talked to Sam Altman I think
oh this is what it would have been like
to talk to Bill Gates when he was 20
years old and I was just like what an
epic call for a guy who's now gone gone
on to do some pretty amazing things
there was a story I'd never heard though
or two stories I thought were pretty
remarkable
um I think there was a situation where
at his school when he was in high school
there was a protest from like the
Christian or Catholic you know some some
protesters that were like you know uh
protesting the I forgot exactly what it
was he's from my hometown he probably
went to he's from St Louis where I'm
from and uh he he went to a Catholic
school if I had to bet I think it was a
um I don't remember exactly what the
what the protest was but it was like uh
you know uh here we go so basically
um a Christian group boycotted an
assembly about sexuality so they're
gonna have an assembly about sexuality
at his Prep School John Burroughs yeah
John Burroughs in St Louis and so Sam
Altman basically takes the mic announces
that he's gay and then asks the school
whether they want to be a repressive
place or a place open to different ideas
baller and and then baller right yeah
and then the college counselor goes what
Sam did changed the school it felt like
somebody opened up a big box and then
all the and then all kids of all kinds
got to be let out into the world like
you know it just kind of like it drew a
line publicly that's a really good uh
way to describe it by the way and that
is that is just an amazing story I love
that story um he also talked about like
okay I want to read you some other
amazing quotables because this guy's
kind of remarkable and we just respect
people who kind of like what you say let
the freak flag fly that people who just
like do life their way and their way
happens to be different than like the
craziest thing that he did was he did a
speech about announcing something big
and he wore two double popped collars
that were pink and green I love that guy
I thought I remember seeing that I like
your old conference like a big deal a
life highlight for most people
um there's all these amazing anecdotes
from these these articles that I was
reading so one because
um so they got uh so they got in uh him
and his brothers he's got uh Brothers
Jack and uh
Max and so they uh one of them started
this company called lattice and like you
know he had some phrase about what
lattice was doing and uh and so uh Sam
invests in Asana the a different company
and he writes this blog post about like
you know just quickly you have the
morning of kind of writes this um
where's this blog post where he goes uh
how did he goes he goes he goes um yeah
I uh you know I invest in a sauna
because I think it's great it's gonna
make people more productive because they
do a b and c and it turns out that a b
and c were like the same marketing
material that Jack his brother was using
for lattice and so the article's talking
about it's like Jack's like super pissed
he's like dude you just invested in them
for the exact you know that's our
mission statement why are you saying
they do it and Sam's like oh dude like
I'm so I totally I must have just
totally spaced like I must have heard
you say that so many times over the
years that like it just kind of became
like a a set of words I know I totally
didn't intend that edited edits it but
Jack's mad calls the mom and it's like
you know Sam did this and they're and
Sam's like are you still mad at me or
whatever and they're fighting and then
they're like and then the end the story
goes like uh like and then Jack looks
over at a board game called Samurai
that's on their bookshelf in their home
and says you know Sam won every single
game of Samurai when we were kids and
always declared himself the samurai
leader because he's he always has to win
he's always in charge of everything this
is oh and then says Samuel been shot
back you want to play speed chess right
now know
I read this and I was like that's
literally like if Chad I told chat GPT
to like make up a story about like young
Silicon Valley nerds who are compared of
a competitive streak you know like oh
yeah it's called Alpha land you gotta
take this outside and play some speed
chess instead of see who's the real man
yeah that's Alpha land in Silicon Valley
yeah so I thought that was hilarious
there's another one that I thought was a
kind of an amazing thing so
did you know that at some point he
basically sold what did he do he sold
um
yeah so the The Story Goes he decided to
get rid of all his uh you know Comforts
except for uh you know three or four
things so he kept a four bedroom house
in San Francisco he kept his cars
because he loves cars it was like a
mclareness he has two McLarens and
something else he kept a property on Big
Sur in case the the world ends and um
and then he has a reserve of 10 million
dollars and he's like the annual
interest should cover my living expenses
and I could just spend the rest of my
money and the rest of my time trying to
improve humanity and so he's like I just
whittled it down to what are the things
I really care about yeah what do I need
the essentials in my McLarens my 10
million dollar you know whatever and it
sounds a little like trite because it's
like oh yeah dude like that's it
but in reality like if you know people
in Silicon Valley like there's a
never-ending appetite for more more Fame
More Money More Everything
um and I actually think that somebody
who can sort of figure out
do just accruing these these money
points doesn't do anything past a
certain score so what am I going to do
with this money in my time to like make
sure I use my you know my time on this
this little blueberry cold Earth to the
best Advantage right so I I like that he
had that another thing that he said
about being a prepper that I think
you'll like let me read this quote to
you
uh dude I think he like didn't he like
wasn't he like saying you know in case
there's like a pandemic or something
like that I want a place to go to
exactly exactly so um
so somebody goes like he goes up to this
is the story he goes with these guys at
this uh conference or like whatever at
this Meetup or whatever he's like so
what do you guys do they're like oh we
just kind of work and whatever like what
do you do for fun he goes well I like
racing cars I got five cars I have two
McLarens an old Tesla uh I like to fly
rented planes all around California oh
and uh one weird one I like to prep for
survival and they're like survival what
he goes he goes yeah I have a lot of
friends that are constantly getting
drunk and telling us telling me about
all the way that the world's all the
ways that the world's gonna end and I
read that this Dutch lab had modified
the uh h5n1 bird food virus five years
ago and it was super contagious by the
way this is pre-pandemic right it's
pre-covered so he goes I read about this
lab that was modifying this thing making
it really contagious and I realized that
the chance of a lethal a lethal
synthetic virus being released in the
next 20 years was well non-zero and
non-zero that's such a that whenever I
hear that phrase that that's like oh you
either are smart or you're trying to be
smart either way you've got my attention
dude I have another one that when I was
reading this he kept saying orders of
magnitude orders of magnitude I love
that I just decided that that's going to
be the name of my gang and so if you
want to join my gang it's called orders
of magnitude and we [__] [__] up at
levels
the next previous level dude I'm gonna
have like the the sub committee on that
we're gonna call it parabolic or
something like that like I'm just going
to come up with like crazy names like oh
you guys want to join the exponentials
or not exactly oh yeah it's the orders
of magnitude that's the Crips and bloods
we're gonna say exponentials
um so then he also says this before
opening he goes the other one is that
that AI might you know get really
powerful or be used to attack us and
Nations will use it
um
and then people were getting he goes he
goes you know I try not to think about
it too much but I have guns gold
potassium iodide antibiotics batteries
water a gas mask from the Israeli
Defense Force and a big patch of land
and Big Sur that I can fly to if the
world ever ends that's crazy what a
baller there's also a story of him
walking around with Brian chesky Brian
chesky was about to uh pitch at YC and
this is Brian chesky started Airbnb
Airbnb it was just getting going and
Brian was explaining the idea to Sam he
goes yeah yeah that's cool I think it's
great can I see your presentation he
shows him the presentation he goes yeah
I think we can make like 100 million
dollars a year doing this he goes Brian
do me a favor can you add a zero to
every single number that you have up
there I need to see a billion in Revenue
not 100 million just change all your M's
to B's yeah take all your n's to B's and
uh that that's good that's actually
going to be my new boy stuff as we say
sam you just needed our phrase no small
boys change all your M's to B's
I used to work at this office and they
took the exit sign so you know how
there's exit signs and uh at offices
like above the door they changed the
exit sign to say uh they like molded it
in such a way so it said IPO so the exit
was an IPO so oh it's the IPO side the
exit side uh and I always thought that
was awesome and we need a new sign that
says change it change the ends to B's
and uh that's what he did with Brian
chesky when he was Fire Marshall would
like a word but yeah
the only North Will Survive only nerds
will get that joke so he had another
um he had another
um quote about that the m2b thing he
goes he goes he goes look I listened to
your whole presentation and uh you need
to change that they're like are you sure
and he goes look either you don't
believe what you told me or I'm dumb and
I didn't understand what you told me or
I don't know math one of those three is
is what's true here like either you're
ashamed to say it you don't believe it
or I'm dumb and I don't know Matt and I
thought that's great that's a pretty
baller way to say things
um I want to read you some of the other
uh little like you know isms
um
okay let me give you some more so uh
here's some like quick chat advice so so
I'm pretty into my meme of the year is
that what I call the midwit meme uh you
throw this up on YouTube so you can see
it but it's basically like there's the
dumb the ignorant kind of beginner on
one side there's the Jedi Master on the
other and every in between is the kind
of sort of like stressor type A
personality that's like over analyzing
everything and my goal for the for the
year slash life is to live life like
either the dumb beginner or the Jedi
Master it doesn't matter they think the
same way
um and so and and not be the stressor
stressor achiever type A over analyzer
type person and um and I'm just seeing
that Meme everywhere when I meet people
I just classify them instantaneously so
are they being right now what do you
think you've been historically
um I started off for sure as the dumb
the dumb troll like my first my sushi
restaurant startup that that was the
greatest thing in the world my next
thing yes uh even just when I applied
for my job and moved to Silicon Valley
and got a job with a billionaire like I
didn't know what the hell I was doing
but I was so dumb that I like my
Approach was correct I was like well
I'll just
I'll just reach out to the guy and I'll
just send him a letter saying why why
I'm the right guy for the job and then
I'm Not Really Gonna apply for other
jobs I'm just gonna prove to this guy
this is I'm good at this job and I just
that was my job search right like I
didn't do any of the traditional things
I just did
seemed like the dumb thing to do but
that would also be the Jedi move too in
that case it's like uh you know find the
thing you really want and Chase it with
Reckless abandon don't like just put a
resume on 500 desks and see who calls
you for the job
um so you know I'm still a mouth
breather I think I'm still pretty far
left on that on that I'm still pretty
stupid yeah I do it from time to time
I'll often do it with my econ Biz like
um Suli is my like kind of like Mentor
coach on that side and I feel like he's
the Jedi guy I know he's the Jedi guy
because he's like he said something
about Frameworks he goes everyone in
Silicon Valley talks about Frameworks I
don't know what a framework is and um at
first I used to think maybe I'm too dumb
like should I learn this thing I don't
understand what everyone's talking about
and now I realize they're all dumb
he's 100 right like uh I'd be like you
know hey should we do influencer
marketing for the brand blah blah blah
he's like remember I told you Facebook
ads
just write the word Facebook ads on your
computer and then every time you think
about doing anything else besides
Facebook ads look at that sticky note
again that's hilarious and he'd be like
um if you're gonna call me and talk to
me about another idea you better have to
be doing 500 000 a month and don't call
me about another idea until Facebook ads
has got you to 500 000 a month and it's
like the Jedi Simplicity is something I
like you know Revere now so he had a few
um a few Jedi quotes in this imma read
you he goes
uh Founders will come to me and be like
oh you know what what if um you know I'm
worried about saying this to my
investors because then they're going to
think this that might affect our Series
be raised he goes just tell them and
then he goes uh people are worried about
you know you don't know how your
customers are going to feel about this
just ask them
um you're worried about competitors
don't worry about them until they're
beating you in the market
um and he's like oh you want to do these
five things you're trying to decide like
just pick one and do it most people just
simply do too many things do a few
things relentlessly
another one he goes you need to every
every year you need to think about how
you're going to add one zero to what
you're doing but don't think Beyond one
zero and I thought that's a good jediism
it's like a way to think it is great
without being kind of like
just a delusional talker and like you
know living in fantasy land
um so you had a bunch of those as I was
reading this uh that I thought was was
pretty dope he's um he's great man he I
always see pictures there's that famous
conference in Idaho like the Sun Valley
thing and you'll see pictures
uh oh no the rich guy one the rich guy
one it's like we're like it's almost
like a Davos but or something like that
but it's like all like the who's who I
think it's mostly media though which
includes everyone so like the Murdoch
family and like the people who run CNN
and and you see like you know uh there's
pre ex-presidents there and then you see
Sam Altman and he's wearing like cool
running shoes with like cool sunglasses
and like his hair is all disheveled he
is uh he's very he's a very interesting
character Sam offman's cool he's kind of
been like uh a little bit under the
radar while he's been building his
company but he said something the other
day uh someone was like we're really
hyped about gpt4 can you tell us he goes
all I can say is like people are setting
themselves up for a lot of
disappointment I don't think we're gonna
live up to your expectations or
something like that and I was like oh
that that's a pretty cool response now
now I'm interested yeah he goes with he
goes with AI there's people who think
um AIS changed the whole game and
everything Google search is dead AI is
going to change everything gpd4 is going
to be like you know freaking uh sentient
and whatever it's gonna be amazing he
goes that's that's wrong and people who
think oh chat GPT this thing's overrated
it's a big nothing Burger it's uh you
know look it makes this mistake it makes
this mistake it can you could trick it
into saying this stupid thing he goes
they're also wrong they're also being
dumb but in a different way uh you know
they're being dumb because they're not
realizing how fast this thing's gonna
improve and the other guy's being dumb
because they think it's already there
but it's not there yet uh you know the
truth is like somewhere in the middle
and um I just thought that was like a
you know a much better like reply
um
I also thought there was like a couple
of kind of remarkable little things that
I want to share as well things that I
didn't know about Sam Alderman so that
first fund that Peter Thiel gave him 21
million dollars for uh in I think three
years or so
um
let's see three years or so he had the
fun uh the four years the fund was up
10x already
um so you know that's like what people
want after like you know a 10-year
period in in four years he had done that
um the second thing was how did he do it
he made like pretty ridiculous bets so
he he was like all right if I want to if
I want to help create like you know
trillions of dollars of progress that's
going to come from Science and
Technology not just like the next random
app and so he's like uh all right I
gotta invest in more science technology
so he goes for he goes to Cruz uh which
was a self-driving car company that
eventually got bought by GM for a
billion dollars but at the time nobody
was funding Crews nobody was funding
self-driving cars
um it just seemed too hard like Hardware
seems like an obvious bet now looking
back right I mean that team was like a
plus completely non-obvious back then
and they were struggling he puts three
million dollars directly into that one
company
and the same thing with this 375 million
dollar check that like the lady was like
most people can't write that big of a
check he goes especially not into an
extremely risky thing like nuclear
fusion and it's completely right like
that's going to be like you know a zero
or massive and he's writing massive
checks into it and he did this several
times he puts like millions of dollars
into single bets that he like had
conviction on
he then reflected on he goes of all the
biggest winners
um uh he goes I looked at the five
biggest winners that I have had in that
early portfolio he goes four of the five
nobody wanted to fund they were not
oversubscribed people generally thought
they were bad ideas in fact I almost got
talked out of doing them because smart
people were telling me why these are bad
ideas only one optimizely was an idea
everybody thought was a good idea that
turned out to be a good idea it didn't
even do that well I think well it did
okay I think optimize it did go public I
think in the end so you know it didn't
make it but
um maybe maybe I'm wrong about that but
like I thought it got bought by pe but
like it was it compared to the other oh
no it says they have a thousand
employees I'm wrong yeah it must have
been a hit so so uh the other ones you
know zenefits uh Cruz
um you know things like that uh
basically he was like stripe he's like
at the top now Stripes everything but
he's like at the time it was 18 year old
kid saying we're gonna like work with
banks and change the payments industry
and they ever Do's like these guys don't
know what they're getting into except
for like you know a handful of people
that believed in them same thing with
Airbnb he was early investor in Airbnb
that was not obvious so he kind of got
really into this like non-obvious but
correct mentality which is the the Peter
Thiel like school of thought too like
um he's like the Investments that didn't
work out people also told me those were
bad ideas so it's not that all bad ideas
are good ideas
it's that some bad ideas are actually
great ideas and that that's where all
the returns are and so you need to be
willing to go where it's unpopular which
is so easy to like talk about and it
sounds like oh yeah just do not obvious
things therefore any bad idea I see I
should invest in I get so many bad ideas
and I think I would say no these are
actually all bad ideas that's such a
challenging thing to figure out that's
that requires so much talent or skill I
don't know what it is but it's really
really really impressive and really hard
because looking back Airbnb that sounds
that sounds incredibly obvious but uh
it's just crazy that he was able to pull
that off yeah it's insane so anyways
that's a giant you know Sam Altman gasm
but uh
the guy's just really interesting he's
one of the more interesting characters I
think that exists in the tech world so
uh so yeah I like some of those quotes
I think this was a 10 out of 10 pod you
know so here's how I know it's a good
pod
so it's a 12 30 in Texas where I'm
recording this
usually I go and take a nap till about
two o'clock after we have a good pod
um I I require I require sleep and rest
and that's how I feel after this pod I'm
like I need to take a nap and that's how
I know it's good
all right great glad to hear it
um oh and by the way I'm gonna uh show
my tax return on the YouTube channel go
subscribe and then you'll see it go my
first point on YouTube if you want to
see it yeah and if you find the glitch
uh you might be able to see his uh
social security number it's somewhere in
there
[Music]